Next question today is, hey, David, it's pretty
clear at this point that horrible presidents
don't really increase voter turnout that much
from people who are desperate to get them
out of office.
What actually does or would increase voter
turnout?
Yeah, so here's the thing.
I actually, I believe that the activism that
has been inspired by Donald Trump is real
and, uh, uh, is or at least was substantive.
The problem is that people, um, adjust very
quickly to the new status quo.
And it's been a couple of years now that Donald
Trump has been around and things that would
have been scandals in his first month, no
longer even register as scandals.
There has been a creeping normalization.
So I actually do believe that an acutely cartoonishly
horrible president does inspire people to
vote.
The problem is the election isn't held three
months after the inauguration, it's four years
later and that's a long time for things to
become re normalized and I think that that's
the problem.
But your point is well taken, which is I don't
believe that a lot of the activism and enthusiasm
and energy that we saw in the marches and
the protests after Donald Trump's election
and inauguration, I think a lot of it is faded
and a lot of those people are not going to
vote in November of 2020 so what does increase
voter turnout?
We have a context here in the United States
of non mandatory voting.
Along with that.
We see very low voter turnout, often not even
50% I think sometimes in midterms we have
40 to 45 maybe in some presidential elections
it gets to 55 I'm going from memory.
I don't exactly remember, but it is a very
low turnout compared to many other western
countries.
Usually the discussion about increasing voter
turnout is at the micro level.
I'll give you some examples.
Automatic voter registration.
Okay.
Automatic voter registration does seem to
have an effect on increasing voter turnout.
That's a good thing.
We should enable same day registration, meaning
even if you didn't have the forethought to
register to vote six months before the election,
if you decide on election day, hey, you know
what, it's election day.
I'm going to vote.
You should be able to register on that day.
That does increase voter turnout.
Voting by mail, absentee voting without requiring
a reason helps voter turnout, allowing people
not to have to justify, you know, I have limited
mobility or I'm going to be out of the country.
I want to vote by mail with an absentee ballot
ballot allowing absentee ballot with no required
justification increases voter turnout.
Now one that historically does not seem to
increase voter turnout is early voting.
Um, we talk a lot about restrictions on early
voting, strategically meant to help Republicans
as part of the voter suppression package that
we've seen from the Republican Party.
And we need to fight that any effort to disproportionately
disenfranchise democratic poor, non white
voters, we need to fight against it.
But a couple of studies that we have now suggest
that early voting does not seem to, in total
increased voter turnout making election day.
A national holiday is an idea that's thrown
out there.
I'm up for any of these that are demonstrated
to increase voter turnout, but I think we're
thinking too small.
Okay.
We need to be increasing voter turnout by
educating people who are more connected to
the importance of participating in elections.
That's it.
Okay.
So it's not, I mean, okay, listen, the absentee
voting with not without a required a justification.
Let's do it.
Okay?
But we need to be starting with 12 year olds
in middle school.
And I talk about we need to be teaching critical
thinking at an early age.
We need to be thinking, uh, teaching civics
at an early age.
We need to be teaching up basics of philosophy
and thinking about how to think at an early
age.
This will generate people who are more involved
and better thinkers and it is going to help
the left by the way, because the more people
that are thinking in the more educated people
are in these areas, the more likely they are
to vote for left wing candidates.
But it's much more difficult to convince a
22 year old who's never voted.
It matters.
You should vote.
Go and register then just raising kids starting
in middle school, who integrate the importance
of our participating in our political system.
This includes voting, but this includes being
activists.
This includes writing letters when necessary.
This includes protesting and, uh, massing
and urban centers when necessary.
So I think that the best way to increase voter
turnout, we can play around the edges with
automatic registration, same day registration.
And all of this stuff.
The real way to increase voter turnout is
to from an early age in grain, in every student,
the importance of voting and make it the default.
Not some people choose to vote in, some don't.
You should vote.
The default should be you register and you
vote.
Barring some really good reason not to go
out and vote, that's going to increase voter
turnout much, much more than any of these
little changes we might make around the edges.
Let me know what you think.
Um, big picture.
Let me know what you think at the micro level
in terms of the specific changes that can
be made, what will increase voter turnout
and what will not.
I want to hear from you a send me a tweet.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
Great Program, a great bonus show program
coming up.
If you are not currently a member or a patron,
I guess we'll talk to you on Monday, but if
you are a member of or a patron or
are willing to become one by signing up in
a mere 60 seconds